the Sun's corona its wispy outer
atmosphere has long but old scientists
the Sun surface is 5,500 degrees Celsius
yet temperatures in the corona much
farther out soar to more than a million
degrees NASA is about to launch a
mission not only to study the corona but
fly into it after the Parker Solar Probe
launches in August it will sidle right
up to the Sun and spend the next six
years conducting 24 flybys through it's
scorching Corona its closest past will
bring in 10 times closer to the Sun than
mercury orbit shattering previous
records to protect delicate scientific
instruments from the immense heat the
probe is equipped with a shield made of
carbon foam similar to the materials
that protected the nose cone of the
space shuttle the Parker probe will
repeatedly plunge into the Sun's corona
beaming back measurements of the tangle
net of magnetic fields that shape it
most scientists think that the sun's
magnetic fields are responsible for
heating the corona by somehow
transferring energy from a bubbling
cauldron of plasma at the sun's surface
in one theory the magnetic fields that
protrude from the Sun move around and
get tangled up when the field lines
suddenly snap into a more stable
arrangement in a process called magnetic
reconnection vast amounts of energy are
released into the surrounding plasma of
the corona the process could also be
happening on a much smaller scale with
nanoflares constantly going off each is
powerful as a 50-megaton hydrogen bomb a
second theory suggests that the motion
of the bubbling plasma cells on the
sun's surface excites waves and the
magnetic field lines that course outward
the wiggling of the field lines heats
nearby particles researchers hope that
Parker will also help explain another
conundrum
how plasma particles in the solar wind
escape into the solar system the
magnetic field in the Sun's corona has a
tight hold on charged particles but
somewhere at the edge of the corona they
break free of the Sun's gravity
rocketing out into the solar system and
hundreds of kilometers per second these
particles should slow down and cool off
the farther
they get from the Sun but they don't
they're propelled forward by some
unknown energy by recording the
small-scale physics if the plasma it
flies through the Parker probe will
pinpoint where the wind takes flight and
narrow the possible mechanisms that
could launch it understanding the solar
wind could help us better predict
dangerous solar storms launched by
extreme events called coronal mass
ejections these storms the solar wind
overpowers the shield of the Earth's
magnetic field potentially crippling
satellites and electrical grids the
Parker Solar probes future is definitely
going to be bright good thing it has
some shades
you
[Music]